oder nicht poch, je nachdem
kommt noch ein bisschen auf die Uhrzeit an
aber ich würde sagen 905
ist eindeutig schon poch
ich bin noch nicht so lange wach
irgendwie viertel stunde oder sowas
na, wobei ein bisschen länger
ein bisschen länger bin ich schon wach
aber wach bin ich noch nicht
also ich bin aufgewacht, aber ich bin noch nicht wach
so
gucken bis twitch kapiert
dass da striboll ist
ok, so
oi leute, es ist schon soviel in da so schnell
stream ist erst irgendwie
halb minute on
so
also
äh ne
quasi noch nicht
das ist noch nicht ganz fertig mit dem netz
das ist glaube ich noch nicht
äh ausboch sicher genug
jetzt muss ich noch an manchen stellen
ein bisschen besser befestigen
besser gesagt zumachen
ja, ziemlich früh ne
für meine verhältnisse, aber warum nicht
also ich muss halt auf jeden fall
ein video aufnehmen zu dieser ganzen
home office thematik
dass es ausläuft, weil ich weiß genau
das fuckt viele ab
und was noch viel mehr leute
aufregt ist, dass
ganz viele führungsetagen irgendwie so
ultra boomer besetzt sind
die der meinung sind das geilste was es gibt
ist morgens um 6 Uhr aufzustehen
um ins Büro zu fahren um dann dort
im prinzip nichts zu machen
und sinnlos zu mieten
ich hatte letzte woche
leute, ich muss euch das mal, ich kann euch das nicht
zeigen, aber ich kann es euch mal vorlesen
passt mal auf
ich hatte ein meeting
also zeigen kann ich es euch nicht
da sieht man ja zu viel
aber wartet mal
wo habe ich es denn, ich hatte
einen richtig geilen meeting tag
so richtig sinnlos
war das
genau hier, also
muss man sich erstmal
wirklich vorstellen, also dienstag
dienstag, das war der erste tag
nachdem ich eine woche krank war, wo ich wieder da war
und dienstag, letzte woche dienstag, also
passt mal auf, also ich habe
irgendwie um 7.30 Uhr angefangen und
dann ging es schon direkt los, erstes meeting 9 Uhr
direkt um 9 Uhr
doku meeting, immer
äußerst, äußerst, äußerst spannend
irgendwelche dokumentationsgedöns, doku meeting
danach, abstimmung
serveraufbau
danach
HTTPS, service
da wollte irgendeiner eine reverse proxy haben
danach
change advisory board, übrigens alles
ohne pause dazwischen, alles direkt nacheinander
danach kam
umschalten notfall
rechenzentrum
danach kam
daily, daily bespreche
kann ich jetzt den namen nicht sagen
daily teams besprechung mit x, y, z
dann kam tägliche austausch mit x, y, z
jetzt übrigens, wir sind jetzt gerade erstmal
bei 13.30 Uhr angemerkt
13.30 Uhr, ich habe jetzt quasi
von 9 bis 13.30 Uhr
durchgängig gemietet, was ich nicht gemacht habe
ich habe zwischendurch was gegessen, habe es einfach
ignoriert, dass gemietet wird
danach ging es weiter, rücksprache
monitoring
dann ging es weiter
stand up
das muss ich jetzt umschreiben
ich nenne aber stand up
verlagerung
und dann die sache noch zu toppen
14 bis 15 Uhr
teamrunde
geil, oder?
also im prinzip habe ich den ganzen tag
nichts gemacht
außer pock
gemietet
not pock würde ich sagen
also ich war wirklich im prinzip von 9
bis 15 Uhr
bis Mittagessen dauer
gemiete und dann wundert sich die Leute
dann wundert sich die Leute
teilweise warum nichts passiert
wenn man mehr mietet als dass man was macht
und wenn man mehr Leute hat, die sich
ums mieten und irgendwelche komischen bwl
und
nicht bwl
eitel sachen kümmern
muss man sich nicht wundern wenn das nicht funktioniert
crash 129
dankeschön für den massive prime sub
ein bisschen laut oder?
ja die musik haut voll rein
was ist denn hier los? mario nicht so laut
viel besser
genau das machen wir heute
ja das ist tatsächlich so
ja es ist tatsächlich so
es ist schon ein riesen
unterschied also ich hatte ja
mehr oder weniger so den direkten
vergleich
dort wo ich jetzt arbeite
ist halt riesen
bank enterprise business
stonks gedöns in frankfurt
wo ich beim provider war davor
wie gesagt das war nicht telekom
das war eine ganze ecke kleiner
das war zwar nicht mal startup aber das war eine ganze ecke kleiner
da war das
bei weitem
nicht so aufgepläht alles
dafür waren die chefs
so dass man nicht mal weiter mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten wollte
aber ok
das ist ein anderes problem
das ist eh schon also das ist wahnsinn
echt wahnsinn
wir haben glaube ich mittlerweile mehr leute die sich um
irgendwelche ramenbedingungen
prozesse
eitel konformität und sonstige sachen
gedanken machen als leute die wirklich
die wirklich irgendwas
umsetzen
ja
war eine frage an euch
die auch so im huge business
stonks enterprise umfeld arbeiten
kennt ihr das irgendwann
entscheidet irgendeiner
irgendwas es ist jetzt egal um was es geht
so und dann wird das eurem
chef erzählt und in der nächsten teamrunde
heißt es dann also
leute es gibt jetzt eine
neue regelung x y z
das muss gemacht werden bis da
und dahin ganz ganz ganz
ganz extrem wichtig das
muss man jetzt machen so
und dann hört man nie wieder was von
man hört einfach nie wieder was von und irgendwann
so ein halbes jahr später denkt man
sich dann war da nicht
irgendwas und dann weiß
es noch nicht mal das weiß dann keiner mehr
das weiß dann
hat die leute vergessen es instant
und mittlerweile ist es bei uns
so schlimm dass quasi
die sachen so
viel schneller entschieden
werden beziehungen was heißt entschieden
entschieden werden und umgesetzt
werden sollen als das leute da
sind die es umsetzen können das
führt dazu dass wenn irgendwas
kommt und es heißt ja jetzt muss man hier mal da
ganz ultra schnell machen die leute warten
einfach drei monat drei wochen
und wenn es dann nie wieder
erwähnt wird lässt man das einfach
die leute pendeln so
also pendeln wenn sie so ausweichen die sagen
oder kommt mal wieder was neues
erstmal evaden
erstmal dodgen und wenn es nach
drei wochen immer noch da ist ja ok
dann muss man es machen dann ist es wahrscheinlich was
von den sachen die jetzt auch da bleiben
ja und
ich habe auch erfahren
dass einer unserer prozess
ITIL
big brain leute
die irgendwelche abläufe
dokumentieren sollten
dem haben sie gesagt hey
nicht locker lassen wenn die leute
sagen wir haben jetzt keine zeit mach
extra termin und so nach dem
motto sei hartnäckig so haben wir dem gesagt
dass er eben
abläufe
beschreiben soll das ist ja auch nichts schlimmes
ich hab ja da prinzipiell gar nichts dagegen so
gewisses maß
business enterprise zeug muss schon sein
bei einem großen laden und das ist durchaus von
vorteil wenn man nachgucken kann
wie was eigentlich sein sollte
bloß wir sind wir sind ja nicht in der
lage sachen wirklich verbindlich mal
aufzuschreiben so und das hat er
gemacht der war über einen jahr
wirklich sehr hartnäckig
ich hatte auch mein
Spaß mit dem ja also
mich auch mit dem rumgeärgert er war wirklich sehr
hartnäckig und am ende des letzten jahres meinte
er so zu mir max ich bin übrigens nächstes
jahr nicht mehr da sagt hä wie warum
du hast doch so viel zeug eingesammelt
und sonst wie und dann stellte sich raus
die leute die ihm gesagt
haben er soll besonders hartnäckig
sein und nicht locker lassen die
haben es nicht verkraftet dass er bei ihnen
besonders hartnäckig war und nicht locker gelassen
hat also er hat quasi auch die
leute die quasi das zu ihm gesagt haben
dann genervt mit ja ok jetzt dokumentiert
doch mal euer zeug wie arbeitet ihr denn
in diesem fall was macht ihr in diesem fall und das hat die
so abgefuckt dass sie gesagt haben
den wollen wir doch nicht mehr das
ist so ein typischer fall bei mir auf der
arbeit kennen wahrscheinlich
auch kennen wahrscheinlich auch viele von euch
die so im huge business enterprise
stonks umfeld arbeiten
es wird eigentlich zu 90 prozent
nur gesagt
man möchte was
ändert man möchte was machen man möchte quasi
vordergründig behaupten können
man ist modern man ist
agil was auch immer das genau heißt
man ist
daran interessiert quasi
äh alte sachen zu verbessern
man möchte das gerne sagen
und man möchte es auch gerne immer wieder betonen
dass es gut klingt aber
man möchte es in wirklichkeit nie
machen weil machen
erfordert ja
machen
umsetzen tut ja dann weh im endeffekt
das heißt man möchte immer gerne
erzählen man ist super krass modern
und agil und toll und super
aber man möchte es nie wirklich machen
und
das ist
das ist bei uns ganz ganz exzell
beste story war immer noch
bei uns haben sie mal
vom
ich glaub vom tüv
ich glaub vom tüv war das
die haben bei uns vom tüv mal eine
mitarbeiterzufriedenheitsumfrage gemacht
und eine sache die sich bei mir
schon seit ein paar jahren
aufdrängt ist
ich sag absichtlich jetzt nicht
die führungsetage weil es ist nicht die führungsetage
die obere führungsetage
weil wir sagen wir mal untere so mittleres
management kann da gar nichts für
dass die zunehmend
detached ist
zwischen realität und
wunschvorstellung
weil zum beispiel
wir haben so eine umfrage
mitarbeiterzufriedenheitsumfrage gemacht
ich glaub das wurde ich glaub es hat sogar der tüv
bei uns durchgeführt
und man ging
natürlich davon aus
dass wir super geil
toll abschneiden weil wir sind ja die
besten und die geilsten einfach der absolute
wahnsinn
und da wurde diese umfrage durchgeführt
da wurde diese umfrage durchgeführt
und der tüv hat es natürlich
auch richtig gemacht ausgewertet und alles
und ja genau
so und dann kam am ende raus
wahrscheinlich bis bei einer vermutung
wurde ja so öffentlich nie gesagt
dann kam am ende raus naja
die playlist sagt die playlist
unterschiedlich laut unterschiedlich laute playlist sind dumm
so zumindest kam dann am ende raus
das ist jetzt meine
vermutung dass wir doch nicht so
ultimativ genial geil
sind und die besten der besten
und so und
zumindest hat man dann folgenden trick
angewandt dass das nicht so schlecht
ausgesehen hat
und zwar
als die ergebnisse
dieser umfrage vorgestellt wurden
jetzt kommt ja eigentlich der hammer
hat man nicht einfach nur
absolut die zahlen genannt
dann hätte man nämlich gesehen
dass unsere noten gar nicht so gut
sind ja
unterschiedlich sagen wurden von 1 bis 6
bewertet zum beispiel war ein
zahllagepunkt das weiß ich noch wie klar
sind aufgaben formuliert
und das habe ich halt total schlecht bewertet
weil unsere aufgaben sind vielleicht
formuliert aber nicht klar
ja genau so dinge haben wir
solche sachen wurden
da gefragt ja
und
in absoluten zahlen noten
war das halt nicht so gut also was
hat man jetzt gemacht man konnte sich ja nicht hinstellen
und sagen hm also das ergebnis
ist doch nicht so geil wie wir uns das vorgestellt
haben vielleicht ist unser
darauf doch nicht so realitätsnah
gewesen wir müssen da mal was ändern oder
wir müssen da uns mal gedanken drüber machen
hat man nicht gemacht man hat sich ein
vergleichsergebnis eingekauft
anonymisiert von
irgendeinem x-beliebischen anderen unternehmen die der tÜV
auch befragt hat mit anonymisierten
daten natürlich du wusstest nicht wen und die waren
schlechter als wir was ja kein wunder
ist ich meine wenn die die umfrage ein paar mal durchgeführt
haben irgendwie du wirst immer andere
unternehmen finden die noch schlechter sind
sondern hat man also quasi nicht die noten
vorgestellt so in absoluten noten so nach dem
motto hier haben wir eine 3,4 hier
haben wir eine 2 hier haben wir eine 4,5
und sowas nein sondern man hat nur noch die
noten vorgestellt im vergleich
zu diesem anderen vergleichs
umfrage
werte wie man halt genommen
hat die halt eben besonders schlecht waren oder so
und dementsprechend hieß es
dann von anfang an die umfrage ist
durch und was ist es ein sehr
ein herausragendes
ergebnis wurde uns
dann präsentiert und da
während wir das vorgestellt haben kam mir das schon
extrem spanisch vor weil wir hatten
halt in vielen sachen keine wirklich guten
noten wir hatten halt irgendwie 3,4
teilweise 4 manchmal auch 2
also das war sehr
durchwachsen da habe ich mir gedacht
das ist doch im leben kein gutes ergebnis
ja und am ende wo es dann darum ging so nach dem
motto was hat man da eigentlich gesehen
hat man rausbekommen ja das war
eigentlich keine vorstellung der noten
das war eine vorstellung unserer noten versus
irgendein
anderen umfrage
also versus verglichen mit irgendeiner
anderen umfrage und ich meine ganz ehrlich
ich man kann sich immer gut
dastehen lassen wenn man den vergleichswert selbst
auswählen kann also wenn ich jetzt richtig
kacke bin ich finde immer noch
einen der noch schlechter ist und wenn ich mich da mit dem
vergleich kann ich sagen herausragend
gutes ergebnis
also solche dinger solche dinger machen
wir wirklich gerne und
ja
wir lassen uns halt auch immer zu solchen
aussagen hinreißen so nach dem motto
ja wir wissen ja um unsere schwächen
und dann passiert nie was das ist es
typisch bürstens enterprise stonks geht und mittlerweile
ist mir das egal früher hat mich das
immer noch ein bisschen aufgeregt da habe ich gesagt wie
kann das denn so weit auseinander gehen zwischen
dem was wir immer sagen und tun
und das was
wirklich dache ist
also das ist ja riesen diskrepanz
es ist bei jedem unternehmen erzählt
mir ein unternehmen was nicht intern erzählt
sie sind die besten und geilsten
in ihrem bereich und sonst wie was
das macht eigentlich jeder also
jeder zumindest wo ich bisher gewesen bin macht
macht das das machen die alle
aber
also da wo ich aktuell bin da geht es schon ziemlich stark
auseinander weil wir
sind extrem gut im selber loben
und wir sind in vielen bereichen gar nicht
mal so geil wie man das gerne
hätte und
das ist
teilweise schon witzig
ja es ist
ähnlich
bei uns ist es
eher so wir machen
das klappt ja mittlerweile
ganz gut wenn was in die hose gegangen
ist wird jetzt doch
öfters schonmal im nachhinein geguckt
warum was in die hose gegangen
ist das heißt aber noch lange nicht dass
wir das nächste mal nicht wieder das gleiche problem haben
also
bei uns ist es doppelt
schlimm wir analysieren oftmals
nach problemen was denn das
wenn irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist zum beispiel was denn das
problem war nur
aus dieser analyse die gar nicht
schlecht ist die oftmals auch wirklich
den kern des
problematik findet ist
es passiert dann nichts
und dementsprechend haben wir das nächste mal
das gleiche problem
wie
oft habt ihr
mitarbeitergespräche also
ich habe also muss man
unterscheiden ich habe einmal
im monat
eine stunde
eineinhalb glaube eineinhalb stunden ist es
gespräch mit meinem chef wo es
um alles mögliche geht
da gehts von ich will mal wieder
mehr geld zu ich mach aktuell
das und das oder warum das
neue battlefield müll ist
da gehts im Prinzip um alles
gehen einfach eineinhalb
stunden oder eine stunde ist glaube ich egal
ein termin einmal im monat wo man irgendwie
alles mögliche ansprechen kann und dann
haben wir einmal im jahr was
offizielles mit formula
wo man dann so gewisse
sachen durch exerzieren muss
mit benoten
von irgendwie
sachen und was
ich pläne und keine ahnung
das hatte ich aber schon eine ganze weile nicht mehr gehabt
weil ich war jetzt krank da war das zufällig
in der woche jetzt war mein chef krank wo wir es
umgelegt aber gucken wenn wir beide wieder da
sind dann klappt das hoffentlich
ja
wir haben gestern kurz über sveltele gesprochen braucht man sveltele überhaupt
noch eine separate api um zum beispiel auf
datenbank zuzugreifen löst man das einfach
das kannst du machen wie du lustig bist also
wenn dir die server side funktionen
ausreichen die du da
in deine komponenten reinschreibst
das dann brauchst du dann brauchst du
keine separate api
du kannst das
du kannst das da das meiste da drin
machen
aber
eigentlich eigentlich ist das so nicht
ist das so nicht gedacht ne keine ahnung ich
hab da auch keine große ahnung von
ich hab noch nie eine wirklich
server side
rendering svelte
kit app gehabt die irgendwo
betrieben keine ahnung
weiß ich nicht
also du brauchst manche sachen aber schon als
also ich glaube die datenbank
managen
in der svelte kit anwendung ist nicht
so schön weil du hast ja trotzdem
komponenten basiert weiterhin
du kannst in der svelte kit anwendung
kannst du sagen was du auf dem server beispielsweise
schon fetschen willst und direkt zum
client rüber schicken willst aber jetzt
quasi sich datenbank
zeden initialisieren und so was
das würde ich wahrscheinlich eher nicht
in der svelte kit anwendung machen
ja ich denke auch dass es theoretisch
machen kann ich weiß nicht ob man das machen will
ich mein svelte kit kompiliert dann im endeffekt
irgendeine node.js anwendung da kannst du bestimmt
irgendeine main komponent machen die auf dem
server läuft keine ahnung aber
ich würde wahrscheinlich
ich mache es immer so ich weiß
natürlich nicht ob es der weißheit letzter schluss ist
also ich benutze
in letzter zeit das fürs frontend
und wenn man besonders
daten intensive sachen hat
seiten wo lange tabellen und so was
drin sind die kann man ja schon auf dem server
auf der server seite rendern
und dann
zum frontend schicken
also meine kombination
in letzter zeit ist svelte kit plus asp.net
core für api
geschichten und datenbank
ja moving targets
ja das haben sie auch immer das haben sie auch immer
wieder gerne
ja
gut wunderbar dort das
weiß ich wie ich jetzt darauf gekommen bin aber
so siehts aus
lohnt sich das ach stimmt
haben die wieder haben die neue videos
lohnt sich was steuer vorteile
durch steuer vorteile durch heiraten
mit wem lohnt es sich ich glaube
das das blödeste was
man machen kann ist nur wegen steuer vorteilen
zu heiraten
das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
dann wirklich der weißheits
letzter schluss ist
arbeit im job center
quer einstieg
zur arbeit oh das würde ich
im leben nicht machen wollen leute
das würde ich im leben
nicht machen wollen
also wenn eine sache glaube ich
noch schlimmer als lehrer ist
an den ich letzten sind lehrer
was verdient ein lehrer
also wenn es eine sache ist die ich
noch
weniger
ach hier guck mal das ist die die excel
die excel tabellen gemacht hat
also wenn ich eine sache noch weniger machen will
als lehrer werden dann ist es jobvermittler
ach hier ist der lehrer genau
der
war ja wirklich sympathisch konnte es ja nichts sagen aber
ich würde es trotzdem im leben nicht machen wollen
aber das würde ich auch nicht machen wollen also ganz
ehrlich job center job
vermitteln bloß nicht hör mal auf
so
wir lassen uns jetzt eine runde level cap
bäden wie wir das immer machen am anfang des streams
gibt da verschiedene dinge habe ich gesehen du kannst ja
du kannst ja irgendwie eine
node.js anwendung rausfallen lassen du kannst
aber auch eine
mehr oder weniger static anwendung rausfallen lassen
die du dann
über irgendeinen webserver da gehen
natürlich manche sachen da nicht mit
ich kann in der static anwendung
eben kein
fetschen auf server seite oder sowas machen
gibt noch mehr adapter fand ich eigentlich
von der idee her ganz nice
so wir lassen
uns mal eine runde level cap gbade
Leute
level cap gbade mal gucken was
neues gibt
Moment Moment
habe ich das richtig verstanden
battlefield hat einen narrative director
da ist aber wenig zu sehen
in battlefield 2042 drin
dass das spiel ein narrative
hätte
Elden ring ist halt auch ein spiel was
gut geworden ist
ernsthaft
also
muss ich anders fragen
ihr wisst ja ich habe overwatch tausende
stunden gegen also ich habe wirklich so
extrem viel overwatch gespielt ich glaube ich habe
kaum ein anderes spiel die letzten
jahre so viel und so ausführlich
gespielt wie overwatch und dementsprechend
ja
schmerzt es mir immer noch so wie das mit
blizzard und overwatch gelaufen ist
bzw. nicht gelaufen
ist und wie viel da wieder obwohl es
eigentlich offensichtlich war dass es in die hose geht
gerade auch richtung overwatch liegt und alles
mögliche verkackt
wurde ja also e-sport mäßig wurde also fast
alles verkackt was man verkacken kann
zumindest
mich lässt overwatch 2 komplett
kalt
mich lässt es komplett kalt
das ist mir
es juckt mich einfach nicht
die können also die müssten wirklich
grundlegend nicht nur am
nicht nur an dem game
bzw. am game weniger
an ihrer einstellung wie sie das game behandeln
äh was ändern
ich meine die sind mit ihren patches schneller
geworden aber die content
dichte ist halt nicht vorhanden du kriegst
irgendwie jetzt über 4 jahre hinweg hast du was
was ich 5 hellen und 5 maps gekriegt
oder sowas am anfang ein bisschen mehr
also es ist halt wirklich ich sage jetzt
einfach mal 5 es ist wahrscheinlich mittlerweile
sogar ein bisschen mehr aber es ist halt
echt
nicht das
was du machen musst um die leute bei
der stange zu halten das gameplay an sich ist
super ähm
motivierend wenn es nicht so diese typischen
overwatch abfuck
elemente hätte ich verstehe bis heute
nicht warum es bei 2cp
die spawns 2 meter
vom letzten von der letzten flagge weg sein müssen
das ist einfach nur das fühlt sich einfach
immer noch nicht richtig an
ja auch dass die team compositions so extrem
dynamisch sind das spiel war ja eigentlich
mal gedacht dass man
in einer runde 5 6 mal
den held wechselt deswegen gab es ja
am anfang auch keine restriction wie auf der
gleiche held gepickt werden kann sowas das hat aber
einfach nicht funktioniert
ähm
das fängt ja schon damit an dass sie die
spieleanzahl jetzt
reduziert haben so nach dem motto hier
übrigens ihr lieben pro teams ihr müsst jetzt einen kicken
es war ja 6 vs 6 jetzt ist es
5 vs 5 es ist natürlich einfacher
5 vs 5 zu machen
als 6 vs 6 aber
und e-sport
technisch haben sie so ziemlich alles verkackt was du verkacken kannst
die haben ich meine ernsthaft
hat noch jemand overwatch league geguckt
seit sie auf youtube ist ich nicht
und selbst davor war das große problem
was overwatch hat e-sport technisch übrigens
das gleiche was sie bei call of duty
auch verkacken die haben
ihre overwatch league und sie haben nichts
sie haben keinen
ich weiß dass sie es haben aber es
interessiert keinen sie haben kein richtiges
tier 1 tier 2 tier 3
amateurgeschichten sonst was
du hast theoretisch contenders
was nirgendswo beworben wird was wirklich
absolut keine sau auch nur
ansatzweise interessiert
und du hast eben du hast keine
du hast keine wirkliche
e-sport szene in diesem spiel
es spielt auch kaum jemand du hast
overwatch league die
rekrutieren einfach quasi
aus einem unendlichen pool von koreanern
und sonst
hast du nix
das ist bei call of duty läuft
eh nicht du hast nix cs zeigt
wie das richtig funktioniert
cs hast du auf allen auf allen ebenen
cs hast du hier wirklich es tier
du hast
tier du hast regionale sachen
irgendwelche deutschland league und sonst was
cs kannst du theoretisch
wenn du sagen würdest
ich bin richtig gerade
begeistert von cs und ich will mich da jetzt richtig
reinhängen das kannst du jetzt
die haben sowas wie faceit und solche
geschichten bei cs du kannst sagen jawoll
ich fange jetzt an wirklich hardcore
competitive cs zu grinden
und dann kannst du quasi von deinem jetzigen
skill level
wenn es jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie
eh ganz
ganz unten ist aber kannst du theoretisch
von deinem jetzigen skill level anfangen
direkt competitive
cs zu spielen und dich hoch zu grinden
mit deinem team
und
diese sachen gibt es
in overwatch einfach nicht
es ist ja schön
wenn die player feedback lesen das problem ist
dass keine spieler mehr übrig sind
schauen wir mal wie war es denn gestern so
wahnsinn wahnsinn sehr gut
es sind halt keine spieler mehr da
und es ist jetzt nicht so als gäbe es
kein feedback dazu also ganz ehrlich
ich glaube es wurde so ziemlich 90
95 prozent von dem was man
von diesem spiel braucht bräuchte
um es noch ganz brauchbar
zu machen schon als feedback gegeben
in allen erdenklichen varianten und sonst wie
und es tut sich ja einfach nichts
das nächste größere update kommt irgendwann im sommer
es ist
einfach sinnlos
die machen das nächste battlefield
die machen ein neues
battlefield ich sage euch das
2042 der ist nicht mehr zu retten
und selbst wenn
selbst wenn die es retten
also überlegt euch mal wie lang das
dauern würde bis sich das spiel richtig
erholt hat wieder also
das müsste jetzt ja relativ schnell gehen
was es ja nicht geht das geht ja im prinzip
immer langsamer und selbst wenn die in 3
jahren ein richtig gutes spiel
herausgemacht hätten die haben dann
nicht auf einmal wieder 400.000
spieler oder so
es ist ja nicht so als warten die leute da 3 jahre drauf
und sagen ja jetzt ja jetzt fangen wir
an
ja super
das ist ja mal die nichts
das ist ja mal die nicht sagen der antwort aller
zeiten also noch die nicht sagen
was sagende frage
battlefront 2 war viel los wegen ein bisschen
star wars hype und weil es sonst nichts gibt
habe ich das richtig verstanden
die performance ist noch schlechter geworden
weil die performance ist ja schon
grütze
und die ist nicht noch schlechter oder wie
oh mann
das ist so kaputt
wir helfen uns
einige wir fixen ein paar
ein paar sachen übrigens
nochmal angemerkt die haben
mit einem patch es geschafft
dass die maus nicht mehr funktioniert
dass du nicht mehr hoch und runter gucken
oder war es nicht mehr links und rechts gucken
also eins von beiden ging nach einem patch nicht mehr
ich glaube nach oben und unten gucken ging nicht
du konntest in einem battlefield ernsthaft
nach einem patch nicht mehr nach oben
und unten gucken
das war gebackt das war kaputt
und sie haben es nie gefixt
nie nie haben sie das gefixt
das kann doch nicht sein das ist so ein
grundlegendes absolut game breaking
bug warum wird das nicht innerhalb von
5 minuten als hotfix gefixt ganz ehrlich
es wurde nie gefixt
man hat gesagt die leute
sollen in ihren settings folder die settings
löschen und battlefield neu einstellen das kann doch
nicht sein
ja man müsste es re-releasen
mit großem tamtam ja das wird vielleicht noch
helfen
sieht ein bisschen aus wie
awp asimov
gewollt aber nicht gekonnt
vom helm
na toll
die 2000 leute die übrig sind
haben bestimmt richtig spaß dran
das ist ja auch nichts neues
das ist ja auch mittlerweile nur noch
komplette shit show bei vanguard bzw
das was warzone technisch bei
ravensoft so abzieht aber immerhin
ist die basis von im game
so weit ok dass die leute sie immer noch spielen
im build
und hat über 440.000 Live-Viewer begonnen.
Halo Infinite hat eine Mittelsaison-Update bekommen,
die mehrere Probleme hat.
Die meisten waren sehr klein,
aber die Fans sind besonders glücklich
mit den Verbesserungen der ersten-Person-Animationen.
343 hat die Animationen für Reloading und Climbing befestigt.
Diese Animationen hatten keine genannten Interpolationen,
die sie auf einem niedrigen Framerein und mit missenden Framereinen
wiederholen konnten.
Jetzt sind auch die Spieler ein bisschen weggerannt.
Sie sind schneller auf allen Framereiten.
Leider verbreiten sich noch viele andere Probleme mit dem Spiel,
wie der massive Server D-Sync,
was die Waffen sehr unvorstellbar macht.
Die Devs haben die D-Sync-Kompläne erkannt
und sagen, dass sie auf eine Lösung arbeiten.
Die nächste Gen-Version von Grand Theft Auto 5
wurde letztes Wochenende eröffnet.
Leider ist die Rezeption weniger als ideal.
Some fans speculated the upgrade would be a proper remaster
of the original game.
And while it is a big leap in terms of texture quality
and performance, the next-gen upgrade doesn't seem
to be much more beyond that.
It also has some noticeable downgrades from the original release.
Players are unhappy with the next-gen upgrade's new explosion effects.
They almost look...
By the way, wer next-gen spielen will,
kann das wahrscheinlich seit den letzten acht Jahren
schon auf dem PC machen.
...dimensional and have been called embarrassing by the GTA community.
Players are pleading with Rockstar to fix the explosions.
The open-world action-RPG Elden Ring
has surpassed 12 million global sales.
Wow, wow, das ist aber ordentlich.
The publisher behind the game Bandai Namco
targeted 4 million sales within the first five weeks.
In a press release, the CEO of Bandai Namco...
Das sieht man mal wieder, es zahlt sich halt aus,
doch gescheite Games zu machen, ne?
...hinted that they're currently working to expand
the Elden Ring brand beyond the game.
And what this means right now is, well, anybody's guess.
Bandai Namco recently announced their own Metaverse project,
so maybe it has something to do with that.
Some fans speculate that it could be a TV show
or even a series of short stories.
Ach, der Chat, stimmt.
Ich hab vergessen, den Chat einzublenden nach gestern wieder.
Ähm, sagt mal.
Ist jetzt nicht, gibt es nicht sogar eine Halo-Serie?
Jetzt irgendwie?
TV?
Serious?
Ah, die kommt jetzt erst noch.
Also die hat quasi, nächste Woche ist erste Folge.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das was taugt.
Bisher gab es, gibt es wenige TV-Umsetzungen von Spielen,
die da getaucht haben.
Ja, im April, im April ist es ja wohl soweit.
Im April kann man das sowohl mal testen.
Ich überleg mir ernsthaft, ob ich's auslasse, ja?
Also, ich bin so enttäuscht worden von dem,
wie sie Overwatch gehandelt haben,
aber wahrscheinlich werd ich mal reingucken.
Vielleicht krieg ich auch noch den Eax zu,
beziehungsweise die Leute, mit denen ich früher Overwatch gespielt hab,
dass wir mal ein paar Runden spielen.
Aber es gibt kaum was, was so toxic und vor allem so tilting ist,
wie Overwatch, wenn man das, man flippt aus, wenn man das einen Tag spielt.
Na ja.
Ligo Flash, das hab ich nicht gespielt, kann ich nix zu sagen,
aber Overwatch ist ganz weit vorne.
Ja, Moment mal, es ist doch so, dass der Multiplayer-Part
zwischen Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2 gleich bleibt.
Oder ist es doch immer noch so, oder?
Also, sobald Overwatch 2 rauskommt,
ist Overwatch 1 quasi im Multiplayer Overwatch 2.
Es gibt dann kein Overwatch 1 mehr.
Das Einzige, was Overwatch 2 zusätzlich hat,
ist quasi die Grafik-Updates und die Singleplayer-Mission.
Wenn das immer noch so ist.
Starfield, der kommende Space-RPG von Bethesda,
hat diese Woche eine neue Developer-Diary bekommen.
In der haben die Devs darüber geredet,
wie tief die Charakter-Kreation und die Storyline werden.
XQC-Stream wieder Overwatch, da würd ich sogar auch machen.
Ich hab früher viel XQC geguckt, aber bevor es zu pipiger wurde.
Also, mittlerweile ist der Chat ja quasi so schnell und gar nichts.
Also, das ist das Nix.
Ich hab früher, hab ich ihm gerne zugeguckt.
Go again, go again, go again.
Aber in letzter Zeit nicht mehr.
X-Defy ist Ubisofts new free-to-play Arena-Shooter.
It was announced back in 2021 as a rival to Call of Duty.
Based on the early beta gameplay shown back then,
the game seemed to be...
Das wird doch nix.
Das ist wieder so ein Versuch, so nach dem Motto, ach hier...
In good shape, but the general reaction was very negative
thanks to Ubisoft branding it a Tom Clancy title.
Generally, the Tom Clancy name represents more grounded,
hardcore franchises like Splinter Cell, Rainbow Six
and Ghost Recon.
X-Defy's hero-based design and vibrant aesthetics seemed to be...
Hero-based design, ist ja klar.
Mittlerweile muss ja alles hero-based sein,
damit man bessere Sachen im Shop verkaufen kann.
...with the Tom Clancy name.
And it seems like Ubisoft is aware of the disconnect.
All the games Tom Clancy...
Sieht äußerst Tom Clancy-mäßig aus.
Ja, ja.
All the games Tom Clancy branding has been removed.
According to the publisher, this was done so the game...
War ganz davon abgesehen.
Tom Clancy hat ja mit Tom Clancy eh nix mehr zu tun.
Ubisoft hat ja quasi das gekauft vor...
Also, hat er den Namen gekauft vor, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahren oder so.
...factions from outside the Tom Clancy universe.
Public playtests are scheduled to start on PC in the coming months.
Tencent became the majority stakeholder
in the Spanish game studio Tequila Works.
Ich warte noch auf irgendwas wie Tom Clancy's farming simulator
oder so was.
Pappen das doch überall drauf.
...most known for their puzzle platformers.
They're also working on Song of Nunu, a League of Legends spin-off game.
Now, of course, Tencent also owns Riot Games,
the developers behind League of Legends.
Many fans speculate that Tencent is gearing up
to expand the League of Legends universe
through multiple titles with Tequila Works acting as a support studio.
Riot Games is already working on a new League of Legends MMORPG,
so maybe the latest acquisition is to help with that.
Stimmt, es gab...
Stimmt, es soll ja auch ein LoL-MMORPG...
Da bin ich mal gespannt, den traue ich das tatsächlich zu,
dass die was Gescheites auf die Reife kriegen.
...mainstream gaming competitions.
EA announced that players in teams based in Russia and Belarus
will not be allowed to compete in Apex Legends or FIFA 22 Pro Leagues.
The ESL, which is the world's largest esports organization...
FIFA, also EA hat ja schon vor einer Weile
Russland aus FIFA entfernt.
...das schon drei Wochen oder so ist, das ist ja schon eine Weile her.
Das war halt auch wieder eine reine Marketing-Aktion im Endeffekt.
Irgendwie, ich mein, das ist auf den ihrer Seite quasi absolut kostenlos.
Die setzen in irgendeiner Datenbank oder in irgendeinem Webfrontend
setzen ihnen ein Häkchen für deaktivierte Nationen.
Zack, so, Russland raus.
Das war eine reine Marketing-Aktion von EA wieder.
Ähm...
Ob es irgendjemand wirklich interessiert,
war ich eh zu bezweifeln.
...Statement on Russian players and teams.
Their policy is the same as the Olympic Games.
Russian players can compete in gaming competitions and leagues,
but must play under a neutral banner.
This would mean that Russian players compete
with no national colors or flags.
Ubisoft announced similar restrictions this week,
stating Russian players will still be able to compete
under a neutral banner as well.
The Rainbow Six Siege Russian Major League has also been suspended.
Melee-Action-Game For Honor is getting cross-play support.
Wait a minute.
Das lebt noch?
Das ist auch so ein Game, was nicht gut gestartet ist
und dann halbwegs brauchbar gepatcht wurde, ne?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das noch aktiv ist.
...and features and it's finally coming from...
Gibt es das für einen PC?
Oh, tatsächlich.
Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz Spielerzahle gucken.
For Honor!
Ja.
Mehr als Battlefield 2042.
Mehr als Battlefield 2042 hat's.
Sogar eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Doppelt so viele.
Doppelt so viele Spiele.
Kick-weight, Alter.
Wahnsinn.
For players, five years ago,
for players, five years after launch.
It'll be added in two separate phases.
Phase one will begin this week.
It'll allow players from PC, Xbox and PlayStation
to match-make together.
Phase two will allow groups of friends on different platforms
to party up and match-make together,
though the devs are still working on that functionality.
Cross-play has reduced the game's match-making times
and players report much faster loading times.
A closed beta for the Cycle Frontier
has been live for a few days now.
It's a complete overhaul and reboot
that takes the game's original 2019 launch version
and reworks it as a more tactical escape route.
Some new studios have what it takes
to turn this franchise around.
Let us know in the comments.
For Honor is Ubisoft.
Ach.
Stimmt, jaja, dann spielen sogar noch mehr.
Gut, aber kann man sagen, Battlefield hat auch Origin.
In Turismo 7 was taken offline
for over 24 hours this week.
Who cares?
Ach.
Das ist auch...
Warum braucht...
Warum braucht ein Autorennspiel,
dass man offline gegen KI spielt, unbedingt online zwang?
Hat das... Leuchtet das irgendjemand ein?
Man weiß es nicht.
Wann versteht es nicht?
Okay, wenn ein Spiel die Konsole beschädigen kann,
dann ist schon Hardcore was kaputt.
Jawoll.
Okay, wir wissen Bescheid.
Wir haben uns von Levelcap jebaiten lassen.
Er hat gar nicht so sehr jebaitet.
Aber éste Woche, die Woche, die Woche.
So.
Was empfiehlt uns den YouTube sonst?
Was? Remember this glitch? Nein. Zu spät.
A real day in the life of a 21-year-old software engineer.
Wie? Real?
Real das heißt, er arbeitet auch was oder wie?
Das heißt, er ist nicht, wie in diesen Werbevideos,
den ganzen Tag nur am rumlaufen,
am Flipper spielen
oder am äh...
mieten, wipe us off.
ja das glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe weil wenn man den werbe videos glaubt dann macht dann
arbeitet man ja eigentlich nix jetzt im ernst ja erstmal schöne mechanische tastatur so muss das
sein was ich auch nicht verstehe ist wie kommen die leute ohne num block klar
chat seid ihr num block enjoyer oder nicht wir machen mal kurz ne umfrage
moment num block machen mal kurz ne umfrage num block enjoyer fragezeichen ja nein so dauer eins
mal gespannt ob wir viele num block enjoyer haben
der num block hat ist ein steuerberater das ist immer so weit gehen die ansichten auseinander
ja nein ok
es wird geht
Mein Laborlaptop ist hinter der Kamera.
Du wirst das leider nicht sehen, also los geht's.
Team-Meeting, ja. Muss ja sein.
Immer, immer Gemiete, ganz Tag.
Wie er arbeitet.
Wo kommen wir denn dahin, dass der einfach arbeitet?
Ich glaube, es hackt. Der kann doch nicht einfach arbeiten.
Das ist eine gute Idee, Essen zu holen mit einem Fahrrad,
ein bisschen Bewegung.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich morgens und mittags,
wenn ich vom und zum Südbahnhof laufe,
dass ich insgesamt mal so eine Stunde unterwegs gewesen bin.
Hier daheim ist kein Problem,
hier daheim laufe ich einfach mittags 1-2 Stunden rum.
Aber ein bisschen Bewegung ist echt für alles gut.
Hätte mir das einer vor 10 Jahren gesagt,
hätte ich gesagt, es mag halt die Klappe.
Es ist einfach nicht zu unterschätzen.
Man hat viel weniger Kopf- wie Rückenprobleme sonst was,
einfach ein bisschen Bewegung.
Hilft viel mehr, als man wahrhaben will.
Obwohl es eigentlich jeder weiß.
Oh, was ist das für ein super agiles Fahrrad?
Agile as fuck.
So, erst mal eine Runde.
Ich bin jetzt auf dem Weg nach Hause.
Chicken, oder was, was es da oben gab?
Chicken-Tariaki.
Ist das ein Rasierer?
Nee, das ist eine Gabel.
Das, wisst ihr, wie das aussieht?
Das sieht aus wie ein Rasierer-Aufsatz,
um sich den Bart zu schneiden.
Aber das sind wahrscheinlich zwei Gabel.
Der arbeitet ja schon wieder.
Was ist mit den Leuten los?
Wollen die uns wirklich sagen,
dass man als Software-Entwickler auch mal arbeiten muss?
Also wenn ich mir die ganzen Werbevideos
und wie bei uns ein Tag-Videos aussieht,
dann bestehen die aus Meetings,
zwischendurch Tischkicker spielen,
danach zwischendurch mieten,
dann in der Cafeteria abhängen,
dann eine Runde Switch spielen,
dann wieder in der Cafeteria abhängen,
dann kostenloses Obst aus dem Obstkorb sammeln,
danach, weil man sich so gut versteht
und so dicke mit allen ist,
zusammen noch ins Fitnessstudio gehen
und dann 22 Uhr heimkommen und sagen,
oh, war das ein geiler Arbeitstag.
Also, ich dachte, so ist das,
aber der muss ja wirklich arbeiten für sein Geld.
So, alles, was ich sagen soll, gibt es hier.
Social Media Break.
Ich muss mich jetzt mal outen,
ich mache Social Media Breaks während dem Homeoffice.
Ich gucke immer wieder, was ich mache,
und dann ist es so,
während dem Homeoffice, ich gucke immer zwischendurch.
Ich meine, ich bin ja nicht die ganze Zeit
hier am Ackermann des Todes machen.
Ich gucke immer zwischendurch mal kurz,
so ein, zwei Minuten zwischendurch mal,
okay, Twitter, gibt es irgendwas, hat einer was geschrieben?
Nee, weiter geht es.
Das finde ich super entspannend.
Ist YouTube für dich auch Social Media?
Die YouTube ist für mich Arbeit.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Twitter, das einzige Social Media, wo ich unterwegs bin,
ist eigentlich hauptsächlich Twitter.
Klar, und Reddit lese ich auch ein bisschen,
aber da schreibe ich recht wenig.
Also, wie gesagt, ich mache das immer zwischendurch.
Ich finde das entspannend.
Gerade auch, wenn man mal eine Stunde gemietet hat oder so,
da gucke ich immer mal kurz in den anderen Browser,
kurz ein bisschen was anderes im Kopf,
und dann mache ich weiter.
Es ist Geschmackssache, denke ich.
Wie er arbeitet ja schon wieder.
Alter.
Was ist mit den Leuten los?
Der hat jetzt den ganzen Tag fast gearbeitet.
7 PM ist was?
19 Uhr?
Okay, der hat jetzt quasi neun Stunden mit Mittagessen gearbeitet,
also ist sein Acht-Stunden-Tag quasi voll.
Verstehe.
Freunde, komm mal denn da hin.
Ey, das wäre mir deutlich zu viele soziale
Interaktionen am Abend noch.
Da hätte ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ich mache lieber den Stream an.
Aber jeder, wo er Bock drauf hat.
Saturday.
Jep, guck.
Moment, der Tag ist doch schon vorbei.
T-Bane Überschrift.
Meatballs.
Oder sowas in der Richtung, ich erkenne es gar nicht genau.
Ja, nee, oder?
Das ist Hähnchen, ich habe es nicht erkannt, was ist das?
Ist ja auch egal.
Wann ist Hacker-Man-Time angesagt?
Happa, Happa, weiter.
Code for fun.
Richtig Hacker-Mans hier.
Was hat er denn da rechts auf?
Ist das Figma oder sowas?
Chat, erkennt das jemand, was hat er denn da rechts auf?
Hier hat er sein Wishlist Studio auf.
Hier hat er wahrscheinlich sein noch mal Wishlist Studio auf.
Sieht zumindest so aus.
Nutzt er Wim?
Nee, nee, beides Wishlist Studio, Code.
Hier in den Browser und das hier, was ist das?
Ein File Explorer oder sowas?
Ich erkenne es gar nicht, was sind das rechts?
Ist der Blick gegen das Fenster nicht anstrengend?
Ja, wäre es für mich auch.
Das sind nicht Chrome DevTools, nein, das sind nicht Chrome DevTools.
Sieht nicht aus wie Chrome DevTools.
Du hast die Corona eingefangen, feelsBatman.
Das hat er mal in eineinhalb Stunden gemacht, easy.
Alles in eineinhalb Stunden, naja, ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
In eineinhalb Stunden machst du sowas im Prinzip,
wenn du genau weißt, was du machen musst,
alles nur noch runterschreibst und copy und pastest,
aber ausdenken, während du das nie nimmst, never in eineinhalb Stunden.
Oder es ist auch so wie in einem Generator oder so, ja, dann vielleicht.
Aber der schreibt einfach nur Comments.
Fake, wer kommentiert denn schon ernsthaft?
Comments schreiben, null.
Mr.Lolfe, danke schön für den Sub.
Guter Code dokumentiert sich selbst, genau.
Deswegen braucht man auch keine Tests,
weil guter Code macht auch immer das, was er machen soll.
Okay, er ist quasi durch, alles klar.
Aber was ich da jetzt schon mal sehr schön fand,
hier haben wir noch einen bei Amazon,
was ich da sehr schön fand ist, das können wir uns später noch mal angucken,
was ich da sehr schön fand ist, er arbeitet tatsächlich.
Und das ist ja was, was mir in diesen ganzen Hipster,
wie sieht mein Tagvideo aus, immer ein bisschen abgeht.
Die arbeiten den ganzen Tag nix.
Also wer wirklich nix arbeitet, ist anscheinend,
ist hier letztens die Unternehmensberaterin,
die ganze Tag Excel-Tabellen macht.
Gut, doch, die arbeitet auch,
aber nicht das, was ich mir darunter vorstellen würde.
Aber ansonsten sind diese ganzen, wie ist mein Tagvideos,
immer fernab von der Realität.
Consultants, ja.
Was ist das für ein Teil?
Alter, schreien jetzt so rum.
Wir switchen mal kurz vor.
Okay, er hat quasi jetzt irgendwie 20 Lego-Motoren zusammengeklebt, oder wie?
Das Box ist hier, aber da ist ein Loch in dem hier,
also der Plan ist, das hier zu haben,
und dann eine Box auf der anderen Seite und einen Pulley,
um zu sehen, ob das hier tatsächlich aufstehen kann.
Also wir müssen das ganz kurz aufbauen und dann testen wir es.
Hey, 5lb erfolgreich, los geht's.
Ja, Moment, Moment.
Du kannst mit einem Lego-Motor, selbst mit einem einzigen Lego-Motor,
theoretisch alles heben, was du willst, sogar ein Hochhaus.
Es kommt nur auf die Übersetzung an
und auf dein Material, ob es das aushält.
Es hebt halt sehr, sehr, sehr langsam.
Das kommt und ist fertig.
Wir müssen das hier aufbauen, aber es kann 5lb aufbauen, um zu starten.
Test Nummer 2, 10lb, hier geht's los.
Wir sind gut für 10lb.
Oh Gott, das war aber, das war aber knapp.
Okay, Leute, jetzt hat es 10lb aufbaut.
Lasst uns das aufbauen und dann probieren wir 20lb.
20lb, das ist heftig, Leute.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Ich bin definitiv glücklich, dass ich meine Schutzschritte benutze.
Okay, hier wir gehen.
20lb in 3, 2, 1.
Oh.
Ja, jetzt flippt man das so aus.
Okay, nice.
Also, wir haben einfach ganz viele Legomotoren zusammen.
Das, ja, mir ist nicht so umgehauen.
10s Arch Boot-Time.
Okay, das ging.
Ah, i3, i3 Master Race, da sieht man es mal wieder.
Aber das bootet wirklich schnell, aber SSD booten halt auch zackig.
Guckt euch mal meine Vm an.
Meine Vm ist auch mega, mega zackig am Starten.
Ich habe da nix großartig, großartig optimiert.
Mach mal Vm an, rebooten das Ding, das ist auch zack, zack, zack.
Und wenn man das noch ein bisschen optimiert,
geht es sogar noch schneller wahrscheinlich.
Und ich habe nix, ich habe nix gemacht.
Nix irgendwie großartig optimiert auf ultrafast Boot-Geschichten.
Und wenn ich reboote...
So, Moment, ab, ab.
Ich sage euch, wann es losgeht.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hängt gerade was im Hintergrund.
Und das Ding startet nicht neu, ist auch geil, top.
So, ab, ab jetzt.
Acht, neun, zehn.
Oh, fertig.
Oder quasi, wenn der Hintergrund da ist, fertig.
Also, das waren auch, keine Ahnung, 15 Sekunden oder so.
Also, ist kein Wunder.
Von SSD geht das schnell mittlerweile.
Real-Life-Pepe am Start.
Also, das ist ja eigentlich nix Besonderes mehr.
Setzen wir den Hintergrund mit Fee, kann sein.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, mehr was ich dafür verwende.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich dafür verwende.
Also, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist echt...
also das ist kein kein ding mehr mit ssd schnell zu booten
ok das gucken wir uns als nächstes an lohnt sich das arbeitsvermittlerin
ordentlich das halte ich jetzt nicht aus why i'm leaving funny i'm leaving
firefox and this is the browser i picked das ist doch jebait das ist das ist doch
das ist doch jebait es war sponsor so muss das sein why no love firefox ok da
bin ich mal dass das müssen wir uns wirklich anhören da bin ich mal gespannt
warum er der meinung ist firefox sagt ich bin auch in letzten jahren nicht
mehr so zufrieden mit firefox wie früher deswegen habe ich mittlerweile ja
eigentlich alles an browsers was es gibt vom chrome jungen bis chrome bis firefox
ich hab dings wie waldi noch drauf das einzige was ich verwende ist edge auch
wenn es drauf ist aber ich sehe es nicht ein
let's start with why i don't really want to use firefox anymore schieß los first
firefox is adding ads in the browser was machen die moment das habe ich nicht
gecheckt so let's start with why i don't really want to use firefox anymore as a
web browser first firefox is adding ads in the browser
echt you can't disable them but ethically i'm wirklich
wirklich ist das so
so testen wir mal ha ha ausfall keine werbung oder kommt das noch
ad suggestions auf der newtab seite
ach hier das da ach das da okay ja naja da müsste man sich auch
beschweren dass google google als startzeit hat und sowas also okay ja ich
kann es nachvollziehen dass man das nicht mag aber okay
not a fan of the idea however well it might be implemented or done my browser
should not push ads to me period firefox has telemetry enabled out of the box and
i have no problem with telemetry if it's up in or data nicht ohne recht ja das
ist richtig das stimmt das ist das ist richtig da gebe ich da gebe ich da gebe
ich ja das brauche ich auch nicht
browser not reading less not an operating system i wanted to display
webpages and that's it ja für alles andere hat man ja theoretisch auch
plugins warum man das drinne braucht ich weiß ich weiß es nicht
ja das ist das ist auch eine sache die ich an firefox nicht mag und ich da
meinung bin sie haben sich von dem weg entwickelt was es eigentlich mal aus
gemacht hat nämlich firefox war ja noch nie der browser für die für die ultra
kacke nur früher war das internet explorer heute ist es keine ahnung
edge und chrome oder was auch immer firefox war ja schon immer der browser
quasi so die bisschen technisch interessierten leute angesprochen hat
die auch auch die die mal ein bisschen abgedreht haben wollen oder ein bisschen
tiefer einschränken also im prinzip war firefox schon schon nie gedacht für den
für oder auch für den 0815 user aber es war immer dass man ein bisschen mehr
machen konnte und gerade das ui redesign gefällt mir nicht
guckt euch dieses menü an dieses dieses hin und her geschwitcht das ist so warum
brauche ich ein tablet menü auf dem desktop das das triggert mich richtig
also dass das das ui redesign ist überhaupt nicht meins
ist ein great on android on ios ist just a safari rapper but the interface isn't
great either in my opinion and finally mozilla is trying to censor the web now
that one is complete nonsense it's a common misconception but it is complete
nonsense
but what they actually asked for is more transparency like revealing who is
paying for advertisements more transparency of platform algorithms
lowering the priority of proven disinformation in all the researches
to study the impacts of the big tech platforms on people if anyone sees that
as censorship they have a twisted worldview basically what they said is
de platforming isn't the solution the solution is to give people more insight
um was gehts ich kann nicht folgen site into what's paid for by whom it's paid
for and basically just tell them this is proven to be fast don't believe it that's
it i'm also not forgetting that mozilla is completely dependent in terms of
das ist jetzt alles was er gegen firefox hat das ist jetzt ja wirklich jetzt
so ohne wahnsinn wenn alles andere gut wäre also das war jetzt finde ich jetzt
nicht sonderlich überzeugend also da gibt es deutlich mehr in firefox was mir
auf den kicks geht zum beispiel dass sie vor zwei jahren oder so ihre plugin
schrittstelle so umgestellt haben dass die addons die früher quasi richtig
viel machen können jetzt kaum noch was machen was eines der riesen vorteile von
firefox war das laufend irgendwelche updates die addons
breaken dass es ui immer tablet lastiger wird
also es gibt durchaus dinger die ich firefox negativ ankreiden würde das
was er jetzt erwähnt hat ist so am rande vielleicht das ist mir scheiß egal ich
finde ganz ehrlich firefox du kannst firefox kannst du auswählen darksiem
lightsteam das reicht in der regel und ansonsten
ansonsten was gibt es hier am nicht großartig
native denn zum aussehen also es ist ein browser
das einzige was du was ich hier am ui sehe ist hier oben die leiste fertig ja
ich habe übrigens absichtlich bei dem browser also ich habe hier für euch
immer da wieder an ich habe absichtlich im browser kein dark mode weil
webseiten in der regel hell sind das kann man auch relativ einfach
einschalten also was sieht jetzt hier nicht so großartig native dran aus die
leiste oder wie
gut aber ich bin auch i3 nutzer ich habe eh kein richtiges look and feel ich habe
ja eigentlich nur noch fenster im fullscreen egal also kann man sich
darüber streiten ich sage jetzt nicht dass es blödsinn ist weil jeder hat
individuelles empfinden was ihm wichtig ist aber naja das hat mich jetzt nicht
nicht so wirklich geschockt
sparsable something that looks like it's using gdk or cute i don't need thousands
of features and extensions an adblock syncing with an account to keep my
passwords in sync das brauche ich nicht mal ich brauche noch nicht mal den sync ich brauche adblock
ja das war es und da krieg ich brauche ich auch nicht brauche ich auch nicht
ja das braucht man
ja das kann ich verstehen das kann ich verstehen dass ihm das nicht gefällt
ok also wenn du keinen firefox willst
und kein chrome oder es ist ja eigentlich bling ist es ja blink oder so wie das jetzt ja
intern heißt base browser willst dann wird es ganz schön schwer
da bleibt ja im endeffekt nur noch safari
was willst du sonst verwenden alles andere ist chrome based oder es ist
firefox
jetzt in der ende wenn ich einen chrome base browser benutzen muss und es keine
andere viable alternativ ist ich werde es tun aber ich werde nicht glücklich sein und
no one will be happy and that's about it and i know they are going to be
compromises that have to be made which is why i'm going to score each option
with a scoring system each feature is worth one point
aha that's it let's begin with the firefox alternatives and there are
firefox forks that kind of solve most of the issues i have with firefox namely
pale moon and waterfalls pale moon is a no-go out of the box it looks completely
outdated visually and looks and feels like firefox 3
ehrlich gesagt ich persönlich mag den firefox 3 look can see myself using it
for any period of time or spending the time to customize it i mean it might
have hidden talents but this is windows die sache ist halt nur die sieht es nur
aus wie firefox 3 oder ist da unten drunter auf firefox treiber da kann
es nicht verwenden
here and that's not a compliment what a fox is more interesting does have
access to fire
ich meine es jetzt wirklich ohne irgendwie ihr müsst es jetzt nicht sagen
weil ich das gesagt habe oder so
ich sehe mich wirklich was ist euch lieber menü technisch oder gui technisch
die firefox 3 optik oder die aktuelle firefox optik mit mit diesen komischen
menus
aber würde mich echt interessieren also ich habe auch keine schmerzen mit wenn
ihr sagt es aktuelle
ich meine ich gebe zu dass das nicht sonderlich an das ist nicht super
2022 aussieht das das würde ich auch so unterschreiben
aktuelle ok also ich mag das hier lieber
or spending the time to customize it i mean it might have hidden talents but
tro emm deine message wurde geblockt war weil jetzt passt mal auf weil das muss
mir jetzt einer von euch erklären warum diese message geblockt wurde
ich ich ich ich screenshot ich ich screenshotte euch das mal kurz
aus irgendwelchen gründen ist twitch der meinung
40 ist was auch immer racist was hat denn 40 denn mit hautfarbe ethnische
zugehörigkeit oder religion zu tun
also erlaubt die message jetzt aber
es ist also ist das irgendwas racist mäßiges was ich nicht kenne wo man
irgendwas umschreibt damit oder so
ja wenn man zum beispiel schreibt was ich ja das ist nice
dann erkennt das dann erkennt das twitter auch oft als als jab so als als
japan racist graben und das blockt es auch aber das kann das kann ich noch
nachvollziehen aber was ist über 40
altersdiskriminierung
das ist windows xp territory hier und das ist nicht ein Kompliment
waterfox ist interessierter es hat auch access zu firefox sync
es sieht modern aus mit einem kompakten look und feel aus der box und es hat keine
telemetrie ads oder unnötige servicen es ist eigentlich firefox ohne
mozilla was ich kinder was ich suche ja es hat auch keine extensions aus der box
also kann ich die eine oder zwei installieren die ich verwenden will und stoppe
an dem leider ist es nicht auf meinen gtk themen überhaupt so es sieht
aus mehr aus der stelle ist das ist halt ein vorteil den ich habe mit i3 ich habe
kein theme ich habe anwendung im fullscreen und wisst ihr was das gute
ist an anwendung im fullscreen ihr wastet kein space und ihr seid nicht
permanent damit beschäftigt den kram irgendwie anders anzuordnen oder sowas
einfach fullscreen anwendungen haben easy ich war wenn man wenn man es als
window braucht kann man das ja immer noch machen aber es ist eigentlich
useless einfach fullscreen anwendung muss ich nicht mit irgendwelchen themes
deswegen ist deswegen ist für mich i3 auch mit abstand der beste der beste
ist ja kein desktop es ist einfach es ist einfach als wäre es nicht da i3 und
das ist das beste
hat ein bisschen weniger performanzen benachbarungen als firefox aber es ist
ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel anders und nicht wirklich bemerkbar in real life
use das macht die attention zu diesem firefox ist auch jetzt von system 1 die
same company that owns startpage they haven't done anything to break my trust
in either of these companies but it's still something to watch for in the
future so for waterfox we have one point for the feature set one point for the
privacy pixel an der seite das stimmt das ist aber weil es mir lieber ist dass
wenn ich zwei anwendungen des gleichen typs offen habe dass ich die quasi
auseinanderhalten kann weil es ein und außen drum habe ich das einfach weil ich
es nicht mag wenn es so sehr am rand hängt ja da weißte ich pixel das ist
richtig aber absichtlich und for the performance and one point for not being
chromium based i'll also add halber point for the compatibility with the firefox
mobile app it's not fantastic but it's okay so we have four point fire monitor
ich habe zwei rechner und dementsprechend zwei monitore ja also hier links habe
ich jetzt meine stream vorschau und und zeug und ich habe also ich habe an jedem
rechner nur ein monitor aber zwei rechner und zwei monitor und und eine software
wo die maus geschert wird
let's talk about epiphany or gnome web
vergiss es vergiss es oder das ist was ist denn das ist das webkit based noch das
kann doch die hälfte nicht im hinter das kann auch die hälfte der webseite nicht
richtig anzeigen würde ich würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
fanny is quite a competent browser and it's based on webkit which is the same
engine that powers safari which is also a competent browser safari ist schrott
engineering engine out there i have to attribute that to blink however much it
pains me to do so but it's still competent enough and epiphany has the
nice touch of looking like a native application as it is using a native
toolkit namely gtk it also has a super dafür nicht richtig und there doesn't
seem to be a way to install other extensions on epiphany doesn't have
its own sync capabilities but it does work with firefox sync which means i
can still use a mobile app with it muss man für e3 nicht eine umgebung wie xfc
oder gnome installieren nö wozu du kannst dir die programme aussuchen die du
haben willst klar du kannst hier den gnome terminal installieren wenn du
gnome terminal haben willst aber du musst kein gnome installieren habe ich auch
nicht wozu
ability to do a full page screenshot though which is going to be annoying for
my linux news videos performance is unfortunately lower than the one i got on
firefox especially in the graphics department where it seems that webgl
support isn't really on par but here again it's not something i really noticed
when loading regular web i swirte ich würde ganz ehrlich ich würde nicht
mehr freiwillig in web webkit based browser
äh ja ne
basis so for epiphany we get one point for the privacy one point for using gdk
one point for not being chromium based and half a point for the sync
capabilities with the mobile firefox app i'll also give it half a point for
performance because it's close enough in the areas that matter to me that's a
total of four out of six and now we move on to the chromium based browsers
first there's google chrome no no seriously i'm not using that thing i
spent years trying to remove everything related to google for my love except
from youtube i'm not about to use a web browser that's going to tell everything
i do to google instead now it might be a good browser or not i don't
know but it's a no-go for me performance is really fantastic though beating
anything else i tested including all other v8 v8 the v8 leute sind einfach way
too smart
du kannst installieren was du willst unter i3 klar ich habe doch auch hier
wilde mischung ich habe genau im terminal am start was ist
genau im terminal am start was ist genau im terminal am start
what the fuck leute warum habe ich putti drauf putti unterlinung ich glaube das
habe ich mal einfach aus aus meme gründen installiert ja ich glaube das
war einfach nur zum sich darüber lustig machen
putti nicht putti erst mal alle abhängig kein putti weg damit ja sehr schön ich
habe ja auch querbete alles mögliche drauf xf ce screenshot tool knoom
terminal chromium als browser elektron e-git vlc alles mögliche
seriously aus seiner sicht ist epiphani
dings ist das ok jeder jeder wie er meint ja
still wouldn't use it now onto chromium and this at least has the good taste of
removing much of what goes home to google the issue is it doesn't have any
same capabilities for passwords bookmarks and history aber da gibt's
addons für and password manager now that's doable it doesn't look horrible
especially if i tell it to use the gdk plus style but it's still not native
looking by any means the performance is top-notch though a bit lower than chrome
but way higher than firefox or epiphani or waterfox you can add virtually any
extension you'd want to chromium so getting a good adblock or the necessary
password managers shouldn't be too much of an issue compatibility with websites
basically ich muss sagen passwörter im browser speichern ist gar nicht so
schlecht unter einer voraussetzung du machst die absicherung mit master
password ich meine natürlich ist ein password manager immer noch sinniger
aber wenn man sie im browser speichert und mit master password dann ist es
schon mal besser als 99 prozent der menschheit
weiß gar nicht ob chrome so was wie master password kann
effect as developers generally only test their website with blink the lazy
bastards and i could use any mobile browser i'd want seeing as the
password manager would be separated from the browser itself through an
extension the chromium would be a good candidate for my use case paired with
something like bitwarden for example of course i'd rather avoid using anything
chromium based so it will be kind of last resort now chromium gets one point
for the feature set one point for the privacy one point for the performance
and one point for the mobile app seeing as i could use virtually anything i
want will i will nicht ernsthaft behaupten dass chromium auf einem level
mit mit dem ding ist das ist einfach meilenweit er hätte was web technologie
angeht was ist das wo es beim browser drauf ankommt ob das jetzt die exakte
color von seinem gtk steam in der adressleiste hat weil mehr ist ja bei
einem browser ähnlich da scheiß drauf im zweifelsfall machst du hier auch beim
firefox in den sieben drauf was halt ähnliche farbe hat wie dein terminal
und gut ist das also ich meine auf web technologien und modernen support kommt
doch in einem browser an der rest ist so bei wer jetzt
talk about break here's one that has been recommended over and over
covered brave and its search engine oder ist video check it out up top and while
it's an excellent browser it just has too many issues for me to consider it as my
daily driver first it looks really out of place even using the gdk plus look it
adds orange highlights the scroll bars much like chromium don't pick up on the
native look of my desktop and the settings even use different fonts and
colors and also ehrlich das wäre mir so egal ob das so aussieht ich will es
einfach nur gut lesen können wie oft bin ich denn in den settings
i use on other apps it also has way too much stuff baked in a crypto wallet
brave reward and an enormous so schitt dass ich das kann't wrap so so schitt da
gebe ich ihm recht so ein schitt bräuchte ich auch nicht
which is ironic because i use katie as my daily driver on my desktop
moment kd er erzählt mir auch die ganze was ganze zeit was von seinem gtk
them ich blick nicht mehr durch although weirdly in benchmarks it doesn't perform
as well as other chromium based browsers it is the only one that can
actually complete motion mark though as all other chromium based alternatives
fail to complete this benchmark its mobile client is good and it can't
sink without an account simply through a pass rate system or qr code it's handy
to start thinking with a new device less handy if all of your devices are lost
qr code zyncing finde ich tatsächlich cool dann hältst du einfach einmal am
tag dein handy an bildschirm und zynchst die passwörter mit ähnlich passwörter
die bookmarks das finde ich von der idee eigentlich ziemlich cool
yes brave gets one point for the performance one point for the mobile
app one point for the privacy but he doesn't get any points for the feature
set because it just has way too much baked in by default that's three out of
six also es hat ein gutes feature set aber es ist zu viel okay
now another one that's been heavily recommended wibaldi wibaldi finde ich
von der idee her wirklich cool ist aber auch chrome based
auch chromium based wibaldi finde ich an sich cool da sieht man auch dass
wibaldi quasi der eigentliche opera nachfolger ist das ist ja von dem
ehemaligen opera gründer glaube ich sogar well and i don't really understand
was hat nie mehr klein und alles mögliche drin ist wibaldi and it's
basically an operating system it has multiple lines of tabs multi window and
panel an email client tab thumbnails a note-taking app macros mouse gestures
translation built-in a contacts man im prinzip ist das die vision die sie die
er früher mit opera auch hatte support for razor chroma rgb a feed reader and a
calendar manager it's also not entirely open source it's auditable as it's
purely css html and javascript but it's not made available to reproduce modify
and reuse the interface is completely alien to my system and it looks like a
windows app transplanted to my desktop i really did it's kind of windows app es
ist elektronen wahrscheinlich für die zusätzlichen dinger
felt out of the box in the looks department waldi has seen capability with
an account as well and mobile apps that look quite good the performance is on
point on par with brave more than enough for my needs
now wibaldi just doesn't cut it for me it might be perfect for some but for me
it's more than overkill i need something that displays web pages not the web
browser equivalent to emax and i would also prefer yeah gut aber ich mein er
muss ja den kram da drin nicht verwenden du kannst sogar runterschmeißen also ich
finde wibaldi von der idee her nicht schlecht source if there is a viable open
source alternative and in wibaldi's case there are plenty wibaldi gets one point
for the performance one point for the privacy and one point for the mobile
app but also doesn't get any points for the future said because okay
wo wir werden am ende kommt als ergebnis raus er verwendet weiter firefox
weil wirkliche probleme mit firefox hatte er eigentlich gar nicht
die same issues it has a built-in base integrated messaging apps a crypto
wallet social networks in a sidebar pin boards a unit converter plus a music
and podcast player and a newsfeed it also has seen capabilities with an opera
account it's not at all what i'm looking for in the browser also opera ist das
einzige von den vorgestellten hier was mir garantiert nicht in die tüte
kommt already have apps to deal with but opera ist schiener chinesen kram and way
higher than firefox or epiphany it just doesn't look or feel right on my katie
or elementary desktop in short opera gets the same
übrigens habe ich euch erzählt dass opera gx werbung machen wollte bei mir und
wir sind uns nicht einig geworden kriegt es jetzt gar nicht mehr zusammen
sie wollten irgendwie dass ich das anpreise halt auch dinge die mir
persönlich egal sind beziehungsweise die ich nicht so toll finde und haben dann
gemeint sie wollen plus mit leuten zusammenarbeiten die auch haben sie das
umschrieben quasi zu voll feuer und flamme sind für ihr produkt und und dass
ich da sache nicht dran markt das gefällt ihnen nicht so und dann ist es
nie zustande gekommen soll mir recht sein previews to browsers three out of six
onto microsoft also was heißt sie wollen sie wollen dass ich sie wollen
nicht dass man das sagt so rum edge ja edge er könnte auch edge auf linux
verwenden kein ding aber edge ist halt auch chromium based es ist im prinzip
alles chromium based wenn sich firefox oder irgendwie all school webkit shit ist
no seriously no i'm not using that one either i don't want to give my data to
microsoft any more than i want to give it to google
microsoft edge has been found to use a unique hardware identifier and sends it
to microsoft to make a unique user profile i do not want that on windows you
can purge that identifier but i'm not using windows so nope i left links to
articles about this in the description apart from that edge doesn't look any
worse than firefox on linux once you tell it to use the gdk theme you can
tell it's not using gdk or cute really but it's not atrocious it's fast with
one of the best performance scores out of all chromium based browsers and it
doesn't overload you with a huge number of features it also supports sync
although it's using a microsoft account which i would rather not use edge gets
three out of six for the feature set the performance and the mobile app and that
basically concludes this little competition final choice also ich
mein eigentlich müsste hier epiphany oder so verwenden aber das ist halt an
webtechnologien für das ich werde mit euch fazit ist er verwendet weiter
firefox verwendet weiter firefox könnte wenden
with every single one of these options now the highest score would be what a
fox and if i was a rational human being this is what i would use
unfortunately what a fox just doesn't adapt well to my system and while it
doesn't have as or telemetry basically removes everything that firefox has that
annoys me i would still feel like i haven't changed browsers at all and i
kind of want to change browsers what ist das nicht entgegen dem kompletten sinn
des videos egal so next in line is epiphany but it has an incomplete ad
block no full page screenshot capability without the ability to add that and its
performance is slightly lower than what firefox offers the other solution
ich nehmen würde ich würde das nehmen was ich jetzt auch habe eine mischung aus
chrome chromium und firefox chromium and bit warden but i don't really like
using chromium based browsers all other chromium alternative also wenn du kein
firefox willst kein firefox fork keine chromium basierte browser es bleibt ja
nix übrig es bleibt ihm doch nix also safari safari
kann er verwenden aber da hast du ja noch mehr probleme mit
that can't really be turned off or full of features i don't want or need and in
the end after a long deliberation i decided to move from firefox to epiphany
performance in real you did really seem to noticeable to me but we'll have to
assess that yeah das ist der webkit chrome browser wurde die hälfte wurde die
hälfte der web technologien die letzten zwei jahre eingeführt wurden wahrscheinlich
ich nicht nicht benutzen kann mit this thing as my god
still keep firefox on the side just in case there's something i just can't do
with gnome web with epiphany but basically i'm going to use that thing it
doesn't have that screenshot for web pages thing i have to find something
else because i use that for linux news all the time but i've tried to find
another alternative browser can i use haben die überhaupt diese
sache da drinnen
es der browser steht noch nicht mal hier drinnen ich kann es noch nicht mal
vergleichen was der hat
kann man noch andere browser eindingsen hier
warum man von firefox weg will verstehe ich nicht kann man die
möglichkeit hier irgendwie noch andere browser auszuwählen ob es den auf
windows gibt keine ahnung
schau dir mal die kommentare an ja ok gute idee hey geis
ah
Ja, da ist schon was dran.
Richtig, da habe ich übrigens sogar mal ein Video zugemacht, da waren die Kommentare
auch sehr 3-Head drunter, Safari, ja da habe ich auch mal ein Video zugemacht, Chrome auf
iOS existiert nicht und da waren richtige Low IQ Kommentare drunter.
Oh man, was ihr sagt, das letzte Video von ihm verwendet er wieder Firefox oder welches
welches Video denn, Firefox, da ist bestimmt wieder mal Firefox hier, one month was not
fun, ja ach komm, ach ne, es ist ja nicht so, es ist ja nicht so als hätte man sich
das nicht gleich denken können, wer hätte das nur gedacht, Web Compatibility, ja ach
ne, das ist das erste was ich gesagt habe, was ich, Alter, was ein Müll, Lull, ne Levelcap
hat uns nicht gebaitet, war schon ganz ok das Video, die dunkle Wahrheit über Flirtbots,
alles klar, was haben wir sonst noch zu auswahl, Custom BCBs in about 2 hours, das ist der
Typ mit seinen selbstgebauten Hololens Brille, der ist eh abgedreht, Powerbanks, what meetings
sounds to interns, can wire shark spot hidden cameras, ok, microservices, Moment, das geht
nur 3 Minuten, vielleicht ist es ja lustig, keiner wurde mir vorhin empfohlen, Alter was
ist das für ein Sound, what the fuck, der Witz ist ja, das ist gar nicht so, das ist
ja mal gar nicht so weit von der Realität entfernt mittlerweile, wisst ihr, wisst ihr,
warte mal, warte mal, ganz kurz was zu sagen, wisst ihr, man hat teilweise die Möglichkeit
gerade wenn es simple Anwendungen sind, was weiß ich, im Prinzip brauchst du eine Webseite,
die sich alle 30 Sekunden mal aktualisiert und irgendwelche Daten darstellt, also eins
der simpelsten Sachen, was kannst du machen, du machst im Endeffekt irgendwie eine HTML
Seite mit 10 Zeilen Javascript drinne und irgendwie ein Backend Aufruf, der deine Daten
im Hintergrund alle 30 Sekunden fetscht, also quasi irgendwie 100 Zeilen Code alles zusammen
am Ende, kannst du machen, aber die heutige Variante davon ist nein, nein, nein, nein,
so einfach ist es nicht, das Daten holen musst du über irgendwie eine Azure Funktion machen,
dann kannst du deine Anwendung nicht einfach irgendwie da 10 Zeilen, sonst was oder so
hinrotzen und es funktioniert, du musst da mindestens drei verschiedene Microservices
draus machen und das ganze natürlich dann auch über GitHub Actions oder irgendeine
CI-CD Pipeline deployen, klar, das macht alles Sinn ab einer gewissen Größe, aber
ich finde es wird heute schon kleine Sachen maßlos overengineert, du brauchst ein Kubernetes
Cluster um es laufen lassen zu können noch zusätzlich, genau, also ich finde es werden
tatsächlich kleine Sachen heute, wirklich absolute Kleinigkeiten heute, komplett overengineert,
also es ist genauso, letztens hat doch jemand im Stream gefragt, Max ich hab irgendwie eine
Web Anwendung und einen Server und wähle das da regelmäßig drauf, bei einem Git Push
will ich das regelmäßig auf den Server deployen, ja, da hab ich ihm ja auch gesagt, ja klar,
du kannst natürlich die super moderne, agile Route gehen, GitHub pushen, GitHub Actions,
das bilden lassen, das auf den Server pushen, wie auch immer, oder aber, oder aber, du machst
dir einfach ein zwei Zeilen Deploy-Script in dein Repo, rsync vom Build-Ordner dahin
und fertig ist und Restart hinten dran, ja, du machst hier drei Zeilen Shell-Script, Build,
rsync, Restart über SSH, das ist bestimmt nicht die super tolle Cloud-Native Lösung,
aber es ist für eine 100 Zeilen Anwendung absolut ausreichend, du führst ein Script
aus, das Ding wird gebaut, deployed, restarted, fertig, und die Sache ist halt die, die anderen
Sachen haben alle ihre Daseinsberechtigung, gerade wenn es ein bisschen komplexer wird
und gerade wenn du dann solche Sachen hast wie mehrere Application-Services dahinter
mit Loadbalancer davor und du möchtest die quasi so hot reloaden, rotierend, dass du
den ersten aus dem Loadbalancer deaktivierst, dann dort updatest, dann wieder hochfährst,
dann den nächsten und sowas, wenn du sowas machen willst, das würde ich auch nicht selbst
über den Bash-Script scripten, da würde ich irgendwas nehmen, was dafür gut ist, sei
es wenn es Linus-Kisten sind, dass ich irgendeinen Ansible Playbook mache oder dass ich es bei
einem Push wirklich irgendwie über GitHub Actions mache und dann sei es auch irgendein
Kubernetes-Cluster deployen lasse, was auch immer, da kann man sich das ja überlegen,
aber man muss nicht Kleinigkeiten so krass overengineeren, dass die Infrastruktur und
Verwaltung drumherum quasi fünfmal größer ist als das eigentliche Programm, das muss
nicht sein, also ich bin wirklich großer Fan von so lang simpel und langweilig machen
quasi bis man da rausgewachsen ist und dann die nächste Stufe, man braucht doch ja auch
keine drei Raspberry Pies mit Kubernetes drauf daheim, um in Wiki laufen zu lassen
das ist tatsächlich erstaunlich nah an der Realität dran
RGS, Barbie Dolls, Ringo 2, BLS, aber wie weiß es, was alle User-Provider-Services sind?
Ja, das ist das, was alle User-Provider-Services sind, was alle User-Provider-Services sind, was
alle User-Provider-Services sind, was alle User-Provider-Services sind, was alle User-Provider-Services
sind, was alle User-Provider-Services sind, was alle User-Provider-Services sind, was alle
User-Provider-Services sind, was alle User-Provider-Services sind, was alle User-Provider-Services
Alles, was ich weiß, ist richtig und wahr.
Und ich werde dich bald in diese blöde Erde legen.
Und dann wird dein Folley für einen Moment länger unterhalten.
Alles klar, das ist ein Blocker.
Kein Problem, wir haben uns noch 2-3 Jahre ausgebildet.
Wir haben viel gelernt heute, lieben Galactus.
Er hätte sagen müssen, wir haben eine Menge Learnings heraus mitgenommen.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Okay, er hat das Problem nicht verstanden.
Wir nehmen das mit, genau, der Klassiker schlechthin.
So, was hat eben jemand geschrieben, soll ich gucken?
Technical Chargon Overload.
Was ist das?
Was ist denn das, 4 zu 3?
Von wann ist das denn?
Das haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Leute, das kommt mir bekannt vor, das haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Was ist das?
Er sagt das auch so, als ist das obvios.
Als ist das einfach das Naheliegendste auf der Welt.
Das ist doch fake, oder?
Ist das wirklich ein Werbevideo von dem?
Was?
Das ist doch fake, oder?
Das ist doch irgendein...
Das ist doch aus irgendeiner Comedy-Sendung.
Oder so, schon geil.
Das haben wir aber schon mal geguckt.
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
So, was hat jemand gepostet, soll ich mir angucken?
Okay, wenn der Chat sagt, das taugt, guck ich mir das an.
Wobei der Chat sagt viel, weil der Tag lang ist.
Ein Rektangel.
Ja, ich hoffe, er kommt jetzt nicht mit...
Circle wird von Ellipse abgeleitet oder Ellipse von Circle, weil das ist ja was, was man nicht beantworten kann, was richtig ist.
Na Leute, das Problem kennt ihr, oder?
Also, ist ein Kreis eine Ellipse oder ist eine Ellipse ein Kreis?
Wir wissen alle, dass eine Ellipse kein Kreis ist, aber programmiertechnisch macht das teilweise mehr Sinn, zu sagen, eine Ellipse ist ein Kreis.
Was aber mathematisch keinen Sinn macht.
Aha, ja.
Sagt mal Leute, ist das C++?
Sehe ich das richtig, ist das C++?
Ja, Moment, Moment, es ist C++.
Ich könnte daraus bestimmt auch irgendwelche Templates machen und ganz furchtbar abgedrehten Shit basteln.
Hm, das Kode zeigt nicht ganz, wie gut ich als Programmierer sein kann.
Was, wenn jemand nicht will, dass man Floating Point benutzt?
Templates!
Templates, jawoll!
Hm, das ist objektorientiert.
Wer weiß, was die Leute in der Zukunft damit tun werden.
Ich frage mich, ob alle verstehen, was diese Bullion bedeutet.
Ich meine, es kann wahr sein oder falsch sein.
Ja, das stimmt schon, also so ein Bull ist, das ist schon ganz schön kompliziert.
Ich meine, wir wissen ja alle, dass Bull in Wirklichkeit True, False oder File Not Found ist.
Falls das noch irgendjemand kennt.
True, False, File Not Found.
Daily WTF, genau, von 2005.
Ehe nur Bull.
True, False, File Not Found.
Wir wussten schon immer, Bull ist nicht Bull.
Bull ist True, False, File Not Found.
Das kennt wahrscheinlich keiner mehr von 2005.
Egal, so weiter.
Wo war man stehen geblieben?
Ich finde es nicht mehr.
Chat?
Wo sind wir?
Wo ist das Video?
Im anderen Fenster vielleicht?
Wo ist das?
Ah, okay, da.
Jetzt kommen die Leute.
Wisst ihr, was jetzt käme auf Reddit?
Die modernen C++ Leute würden sagen, wie?
Du verwendest Raw Pointer.
Raw Pointer verwenden wir gar nicht mehr.
Mach einen Shared Pointer draus, einen Unique Pointer und dann noch mit Cleanup und wir verwenden
ja auch keine Destructor mehr, sondern wir machen jetzt sonst was und ja.
Also C++ ist ja eher ein Fass ohne Boden.
Oh ja.
Da du das dargefüllt hast.
Ja, diese Header sieht man auch immer mal wieder, wo ich mich schon jedes Mal frage,
chat, warum?
Tja, ist schon was dran.
Und den C++ kannst du es ja auch nahezu beliebig komplex machen, weil es ist eben C++.
So und eins hat der Chat noch gepostet.
Soll ich mir auch noch mal schnell angucken?
Machen wir schnell, es geht ja nur zwei Minuten.
Waren Interns nicht Praktikanten oder sowas in der Richtung?
Ich komme immer durcheinander bei den Job-Bezeichnungen bei den Amis.
Alter, das triggert mich jetzt.
Der Sound triggert mich jetzt aber richtig.
Genauso wie...
Ja, typisch Team-Screen-Sharing.
Oh nee, ernsthaft?
Wenn ich das schon sehe, die Leute, die mit irgendeiner komischen Git-Git-Shell-Gedülens
unter Windows rumwursten, da ist schon gleich vorbei.
Netzmuffel, da hast du recht.
Ja.
Außerdem, außerdem ist das sicherlich nicht nach industrieweit anerkannten Best-Practices
erstellt.
Das kann schon mal nix tauren.
Pff, einfach, ich weiß, wie man das machen kann.
Was ist, wie man zitiert.
Das ist einfach.
Hast du Fragen?
Ich glaube, dein Bildschirm lag.
Okay, keine Fragen.
Perfekt, du siehst sehr glücklich aus.
Ich gebe dir deine erste Aufgabe sofort.
Es ist ziemlich einfach, um deine Füße zu wetten.
Du wirst also den Knopf fixieren.
Okay, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Dann willst du, dass der Knopf von vorne bis hinten interaktiv ist.
Es soll genau 7,5 API-Kollegen machen und die Daten zurück zu den AWS Cloud WordPress,
die unsere Mittellinie ist.
Aber du willst, dass es keine Bottlenecks hat.
Was ist mit der Mittellinie?
Das ist Multi-Threading in der JavaScript.
Bist du familiar mit Machine Learning?
Nein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich bist du.
Die neuen Kinder sind wirklich gut mit diesen Sachen heutzutage.
Dann können wir einfach ein bisschen unsupervise Klassifikationen geben.
Und wir können die HTML-Attributen klustern.
Und wenn du wirklich über und über gehen willst,
kannst du auch Bootstrap benutzen, um alles zusammen am Ende zu streben.
Du weißt, das ist einfach.
Blockchain fehlt noch.
Ich muss auf einen anderen Call kommen, also fragt mich nicht,
ob du Fragen hast.
Und du wirst in einer Stunde fertig sein.
Ich sehe dich dann.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich habe schon 50.000 Mal gesagt,
dass WebAssembly und Docker eigentlich gar nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Dieses Thema ist das Thema beschäftigt den Chat irgendwie.
Und ich weiß, es gibt ein Video, wo es jemand vergleicht.
Aber am Ende kommt ja auch raus,
dass es eigentlich zwei komplett unterschiedliche Technologien sind.
Und ich habe schon mal gesagt,
dass ich das nicht so einfach verabschieden kann.
Aber ich habe auch schon mal gesagt,
Und ich habe schon mal gesagt,
dass ich das nicht so einfach verabschieden kann.
dass ich das nicht zu einfach verbindungstonesужig bin.
down what do we have here fine all right this is what I've been dreaming for I'm not gonna let
senpai down what do we have here fine duplicate number given an array nums containing n plus
one integers where each integer is between one and n inclusive prove that at least one duplicate
number must exist of course because of the pigeonhole principle child's play assume that there
is only one duplicate number but it could be repeated more than once find the duplicate number
I got it if the numbers are sorted then any duplicate numbers will be adjacent a simple
sort and a linear scan will do as expected I knew it couldn't be that easy but if you think
that would stop me then you underestimated me I have no choice but to use my secret weapon hash map
the famous hash map one of the most powerful data structures for reducing your time complexity
taking advantage of its constant look up times however using a hash map requires me to increase
my power level so I need to wear these to suppress and control my powers in case it gets out of
control also my doctor told me to wear them to treat my carpal tunnel
seems like you need some help
this question is solving this in linear time and constant space requires Floyd's tortoise and
hair a simple cycle detection algorithm where one star obviously as fast as another and once
they meet you can trace back to the point where the cycle began in our case the values of the
array is like a pointer pointing to indices of the array which is like nodes in our case
because each number is from one to so so do you have to point to a valid index and since
there's a duplicate number there will be a cycle find that cycle and you will have your answer
what are you waiting for cool it yourself senior engineers on code anymore also my
doctor said not to because of my carpal tunnel
that works so why are you so smart because I'm a gangster video ist aber echt gut das haben wir
schon mal von zwei jahren oder so geguckt kennst du es wir können jetzt nicht 30.000 dieser
sorten von videos noch guckt da sind wir morgen nicht fertig doch ich habe zu viele tabs aufmerke
ich gerade aber es gibt eigentlich nicht zu viele tabs das ist euch auch klar oder wenn man sagt
dass man zu viele tabs hat sind es eigentlich noch wenig zu wenige habs tabs
warntapp extension so der chat sagt dass das taugt mal gucken ob das was taugt
sparen sie bis zu 95 prozent ihr arbeit bei und räumen sie ihre tabs in google chrome auf
ja wenn ihnen zu viele tabs angezeigt werden klingen sie einfach auf das warntapp simbol
alle ihre tabs in eine liste um zu machen wenn sie die tabs
bild wäre nicht schlecht und das und das taugt sagt der chat wenn der chat das sagt
also kommt schon mal mit dark reader nicht zurecht ok ich installiere mir das jetzt
wann hat der chat schon jemals was gesagt was nicht gut war und nicht gestimmt hat
kommt ja eigentlich nie vor so add extension gut haben wir es wo ist es wo ist es da und jetzt
einfach draufklicken warntapp beim aber jetzt die musik aus was jetzt was jetzt passiert oder
mein chat ist weg chat ok ich glaube ich gette wofür das da ist das ist halt nichts wenn man
sachen im hintergrund laufen lassen hat das ist wenn man sich einfach nur merken will
und kann ich das jetzt auch einfach restore all gibt es restore all in new window restore
all in new window gibt gibt es da die möglichkeit weil ich will das in einem eigenen fenster haben
und ich will die musik in einem eigenen fenster haben ok naja mal schauen mal schauen ob das so
der weißheitsletzter schluss ist ok da gucken wir uns jetzt an die dunkle wahrheit über flirtbots
ich hätte nie gedacht dass man das flirtbots nennt ich hätte einfach gesagt es stinkt normaler
spam aber anscheinend sind es flirtbots ok ich finde das sieht jetzt so offensichtlich
nach scam aus dass niemand das ernst nimmt aber ok schauen wir mal yo yo gang was geht
ab jonas hier am start für euch jeder kennt sie wir haben sie unter jedem video die immer
lustvollen sports was steckt eigentlich dahinter was möchte olivia uns sagen mit tricks i do not
know megan hotter hoppy sweeter uni cooler yongi butter und was passiert eigentlich wenn man
cute ladies punkt anklickt also wofür ich wofür ich drauf tippen würde wenn man diese seiten
anklickt dass man also wahrscheinlich gibt es zwei varianten entweder landet man auf
einer komplett unzusammenhängenden scam seite was weiß ich mit zigtausend glücksspiel sachen
und sonst was drauf oder man landet auf so einer fake seite so nach dem motto nur hier gibt es die
heißesten girls und du musst dich nur registrieren und zufällig dann bitcoin wallet angeben also
zeug also im prinzip würde ich sagen scam dies draufklickt was hat eine firma in österreich
damit vielleicht vielleicht auch nichts zu tun und eine andere firma in polen und kpop es wird
wild dieses video wird gesponsert von fabulous fabulous ist eine app um sich gesunde nun wie
sie hilft auch angenehm wie man abzuschauen über die prozessei an aber als kommentar wo abschneidet
ihr in der beschreibung
ne das andere erst habe ich habe ich verkaufte die da nee ich dachte es war so anders wollte
sagen es habe ich auch schon mal auch schon mal verwendet aber stimmt gar nicht war ein
fabulous aber habe ich verwechselt erhalten 25 prozent rabatt ok schauen wir uns olivias
kommentar erstmal im detail an erstattet aus unerfindlichen gründen mit den lyrics
eines kpop songs von bts dann geht es weiter mit so with toy in his tricks do not read it to him
that he writes well mammon there only to laugh for a while and not be saddened stress life that is lived
today in fascia in fascia kommen ja habe ich einfach mal gegoogelt und die resultate waren
verwirrend neben allerlei artikeln zu anxiety und depression kommt genau diese wortkombination
in einer page der website von lawrence waste services vor mittlerweile gelöscht aber es
ging wohl irgendwie apple music und was ja zu dem kommet lawrence waste services ist jedenfalls
ein tolles ich gehe auch davon aus dass es der einzige grund hat dass es da drinne steht dass
der youtube algorithmus der spam und scam und so zeug erkennt in comments nicht so einfach
anschlägt mit richtig geschichte im transport in milford bei boston den rest von olivias mysteriöser
nachricht habe ich durch google translate gejagt und es scheint türkisch zu sein aber irgendwie
auch nicht es geht gut los mit ich wurde gesteinigt dann macht lange gar nichts mehr sinn bis zu der
schläfer schrie tiggy yeah yeah die war ein kleiner oyland boy und er missteckt holt ab
über konzerte vielleicht kpop sachen alles in allem ein mysterium klicken wir doch einfach mal
auf olivias lenk macht das auf gar keinen fall nach übrigens und wenn ihr das nachmachen wollt
dann nur in einer linux vm mit aktuellen patch so bin ich 18 nein ach ok gut geht trotzdem weiter
desperate single moms super geheimnisse kann man mir super anvertrauen desperate single moms ja
immer immer her damit wird es ganz wild nichts davon können wir auch nur im ansatz auf youtube
besprechen oder zeigen ok jetzt darf ich nutzer namen eingeben irgendwann lande ich auf einer
klassischen zahl coins um mit frauen zu chatten webseite diese webseite wirken wie datenportale
in der regel voller sehr kontaktfreudiger frauen leider muss man allerdings für jede nachricht
zahlen das ding bei solchen websites ist dass sie quasi entertainment sites sind in denen man
quasi fantasien ausleben könne so existieren die in so einer art rechtlichen grau zone bei
diesem portal findet man zum beispiel in den terms and conditions ziemlich weit unten und gar
nicht mal so groß uses professional animators und operatoren die entertainment auf der jahre
klar also also wer meint dass er wirklich mit der frau da auf dem bild chatte der ist ja wohl
komplett an der realität vorbei das service ist provided in the highest quality real meetings
und not possible with these operators das ist irgendwelche ausgesorsten fiver in der die da mit
ihr schreiben die sender messages within the portal nach mist professional animators und operators bei
denen leider nicht separat angegeben wird ob es sich um solche personen handelt während man 50
coins pro nachricht zahlt und 300 coins für 4 euro 99 kaufen kann das sind ungefähr 83 cent
das ist ja toll fast teurer als das jambaspar aber diesen niederländischen artikel dazu sehr
empfehlen bei der eine solche chat operatorin auspackt wie viel geld unwissende ausgegeben
haben während sie mit ihr gechattet haben im glauben dass sie jemand anders ist die firma hinter
dieser total legitimen website hat ihren sitz übrigens in österreich ob die wissen dass olivia
und ihre freundinnen auf so seltsame art und weise werbung machen für ihre tolle dating seite mit
den professional animators auch das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass sie das wissen und in
kauf nehmen beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich stecken sie sogar dahinter alles egal ist wer weiß wir
haben dem unternehmen eine bitte um stellungnahme geschickt aber bisher keine antwort erhalten ok
und jetzt wird es richtig seltsam in meiner recherche zu diesen wierden kommentaren habe
ich diesen screenshot eines spam comments auf youtube gefunden auf irgendeiner kruden meme
site der post ist vom oktober letzten jahres der kommentar enthält ebenfalls die lyrics von bts
und ich dachte mir ich schau einfach mal wohin mich dieser link führt und nach diversen klicks
et cetera et cetera bin ich auf zwei weitere seiten gestoßen beide sehen wirklich die gleiche
struktur die gleiche automatische nachricht vom support nach der anmeldung da habe ich drauf gewartet
mit isabel 57 zu schreiben struktur die gleiche automatische nachricht vom support nach der anmeldung
die gleichen terms and conditions nur dieses mal für das impressum bei beiden neuen sites zu einer
firma in polen und die website dieser firma sieht fast genauso aus wie die der österreichischen firma
beide scheinen aber tatsächlich zu existieren es gibt handelsregister einträge zu den jeweiligen
geschäftsführern konnte ich aber überhaupt keine informationen finden ich habe danach noch etwas
weiter recherchiert und ein paar videos vom youtuber time works gefunden in diesem hier
spricht er über eine andere art von bots die waren vor allem im herbst letztes jahr eine
ziemliche plage und haben so kürzere obskure urls in die youtube comments geschehen und ich
habe eine dieser einfach mal ausprobiert und die masche ist genau dieselbe nur dieses mal
sieht die website am ende etwas anders aus und die augenscheinliche betreiberfirma ist in der
schweiz ok aber auf einem anderen computer bringt uns die ursprüngliche url von olivia auch zu
dieser website mit dem unternehmen aus der schweiz fassen wir es mal zusammen es gibt zahllose
zahllose diverse bots die auf youtube aber auch auf unglaublich vielen anderen websites wie der
von laurenz waste services rum spammen die strategien scheinen sich über zeit zu verändern momentan
sind es einfach riesige portionen gibberish keine ahnung wie das zustande kommt dass die ich
wissen wie das zustande kommt was ich mir durchaus vorstellen könnte dass sie automatisch versuchen
rauszubekommen welche comments landen im spam und welche nicht und das quasi automatisch
iteriert und guckt im hintergrund welche comments kommen zur zeit in welchem wie wie geschrieben
kommen am besten durch den spam algoritmus durch und die werden halt gespammt und weiter probiert
weiter probiert bis der algoritmus geupdatet wird weiter probiert bis er wieder was gefunden hat
also ich gehe davon aus dass es einfach automatische spam bots sind die testen was gut
durch die youtube algoritmus durchkommt im zweifelsfall auch mit irgendwelchen machine
learning sachen ja ja ich irgendein ai stuff ultra ja ja genau das denke ich mir auch so
andere art von spam bots einfach top comments nach abend wo findet man denn die authentischsten
und zum video passendsten kommentare na klar in den kommentaren selbst die kommentare voller
wirrem text führen dich durch die immer gleichen not safe for work pseudo q&a bei denen es völlig
egal ist ob du anklickst dass du noch nicht 18 bist die führen dann zu den chatter mit frauen
für coins websites von denen einige augenscheinlich das komplett gleiche template nutzen die
augenscheinlichen europäischen firmen dahinter haben sogar fast die gleichen websites und soweit ich
das beurteilen kann sind die wirklich registriert nur die jeweiligen angeblichen geschäftsführer
sind im internet quasi unauffindbar und auch die website des angeblichen schweizerunternehmens
läuft über die gleiche spam url auch wenn sie am ende leicht anders aussieht das alles lässt
vermuten dass es eine zentrale organisation gibt die zumindest einen großen teil dieser spam bots
koalitions müsste man müsste eigentlich mal rausbekommen also wenn man rausbekommen würde
wer denn die leute bezahlt die da chatten dann werden wir der sache wahrscheinlich schon ein
bisschen näher aber das natürlich schwierig wie willst du es rauskriegen schon seit längerem
und ich wollte mich eigentlich nur über olivia und ihre freunde lustig machen der youtuber
theo joe hat ein programm entworfen um es createn leichter zu machen spam comments zu löschen hier
sein video dazu spam bots sind auf jeden fall ziemlich frustrierend weil sie kommentar sektionen
ruinieren und communities letztlich einfach gefährten und es ist so viel spam in letzter
zeit wie noch nie vorher über eine woche alt und war halt einfach mal online unter einem tubi g
bis ich ihn gefunden habe die betreiber dieser spam bots sind natürlich schlau die links sind
total obskur und wahrscheinlich schwer als solche erkennbar aber komm an google das kriegt es schon
hin oder dass das war es erst mal soweit falls ihr ideen habt wie wir der sache weiter auf den
grund gehen können haut sie unbedingt um von twitter ab bis dahin klickt auf keine shady links
jetzt sind wirklich wahnsinnig neue erkenntnis für uns aber gut zusammengefasst naja das kann
jetzt nicht gucken bestimmt zu lang aber leute ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich weiter streben
soll mir tut der hals immer noch ein bisschen weh und ich will nicht dass es wieder schlimmer
wird zu viel geschwätzt gestern abend schon gestritten ich trinke ich trinke die ganze
zeit was ja ja ich glaube ich mache ich muss weil ich muss ja noch ein video aufnehmen muss
auch ein video zu dieser ganzen homeoffice thematik aufnehmen klein für heute ich habe schon lange
kein video mehr gemacht jetzt wurde hals wieder ein bisschen besser ist dachte ich mir so was hast
du mal das social dilemma gesehen nee dachte ich mir so ich mache mal wieder ein video wird
mal zeit weil das letzte video ist drei wochen in zwei wochen zwei wochen glaube ich ja
ich habe das video tatsächlich teilweise geschaut ja und am ende kam ja auch raus dass es eigentlich
zwei unterschiedliche technologien sind was ja eigentlich von Anfang an klar klar war
alles klar leute wir sehen uns bis später vielleicht machts gut sehw